all right Aaron as the whole office can
tell you went to a far cry 5 event
recently wasn't that kind of weird
yeah they drove us out to like a place
in Livermore was like a barn and had a
shoot crossbows and did a bunch of stuff
we haven't actually seen events like
that in a long time so it's interesting
I got a Colt sermon played some farcry
joined a cold back up for two seconds
wasn't that like the main actor the
villain in this game came in on a
helicopter or something that you were
telling me yeah that dude rode in on a
helicopter and we were reminded when
filming helicopters that they really do
blow a lot of stuff in your face when
you were looking at
it's perfect five it's definitely coming
along it's starting to feel like a
little bit like an iterative type of
game like a Call of Duty that you would
get every year but I'm fine with that
it's it's just a ridiculous sandbox at
this point like I know that Ubisoft
games are developed in parallel with
each other but after playing wildlands
it was a little hard to play for Greg
co-op for the reason that you couldn't
get too far apart in it like there was
this leash that kept you tethered
together and in a post wildlands world
that's kind of a problem when you can't
get away from your buddy to do things
but there was a lot of things you can do
this game we were just messing around
we were like roping on the helicopters
Alessandra almost crashed his helicopter
to me after press one button and killed
me very you crashed a helicopter first
and that sort of screwed up an earlier
mission we were I'm good stay up there
we're good that was so it feels like
they thought a lot about coop and how to
do it but they haven't come as far
forward as other Ruby soft Isles titles
like wild land and actually give you
that full freedom to really enjoy it
alternate I hear you saying like the
only the host carries progress over yeah
that's the weird thing is that the host
is basically that's their game and the
guest character is just that a guess in
the host world and well you can still do
a lot of the content like story missions
and side quests the only person that's
actually getting credit for it is the
host and anything that the guest
basically procures like weapons and
items and you know money they'll keep
that but as far as story and like
SciQuest they won't proceed with
anything else feels really dated yeah
you think of games like even monster
hunter like let's do like actually
continue as weird as that game is with
its multiplayer like a let's it lets you
like complete a storage hey there's so
many people who probably want to play
this whole game co-op since it's like
the whole that seems like a big hook
with this one cuz Far Cry 3 had the
separate co-op mode or is like those six
or something missions right and then Far
Cry 4 with just only the fortress
assaults yeah it was like in the world
so it wasn't like completely separated
but it was still like you had to go to a
specific thing and it wasn't fully
integrated the way this stage rule of
law is dead and gone
there ain't nobody protecting us anymore
so we got to do it ourselves only thing
that matters is stayin alive and staying
fed I never played for until just now
cuz kind of skipped a kiss ice I loved
three but it looked like it was just
kind of doing more the same and I think
that stands apart with that game is
probably like it's setting it's like how
that feels very different from the
tropical setting of three so four five
I'm feel like the setting and the
characters are probably gonna be like
the deciding factor in how much I like
this game like you know they're going
for like this American setting they seem
to be maybe pushing a couple of buttons
hey you're that sumbitch Dutch was going
on about I was watching some footage
with you guys with the guy running for
Senate who's a quest giver who's also
her stead hurts dad dude that said Obama
loving Lib tarnish if then Obama lovin
limit chars spandau that I can't look
after my own property I can kiss this
Senate just watching that guy I don't
understand
but tolling they're going for with him
cuz I'm like okay he's not a villain
he's not like but he's he's a quest
giver so is he just kind of meant to be
an [ __ ] am I supposed to like him and
what are they trying to say with the
characters in this game I don't really
know it seems like they are trying to
sort of have it both ways because even
though the game is set in America and
it's gonna be viewed through that lens
of the current political climate as
we're in right now they're also trying
to say that it's its own standalone
thing it's not related to current
politics which again is weird because
you have scenes like scenes with hearts
dad who's talking about Obama loving lip
tardes game also has a character creator
and I decided to make my character black
so stick going on to his property and
actually hearing him talk about like
this sort of deeply conservative and
like you know sort of gun-toting
attitudes that made me really
uncomfortable so but I think that's also
the point where you know you make these
characters like they're they're you I
mean they're supposed to represent you
and your choices but you know you're
also coming into conflict these sort of
fringe ideologies and you know it's it
makes things awkward but that's every
time I'd be into that if like that was
intentional like they're leaning into
that and but I just can't tell if that's
on purpose or if that's just some weird
and it's weird most
okay I mean that's what farcry always
been about though it's always been about
insanity and getting into like the head
of these insane characters and then
having them maybe convince you through
cult of personality or just through the
world being worse than they are they
start to make sense I've had the closer
we get to the game coming out I'm
actually getting more and more worried
than I used to be because Far Cry is one
of those franchises where even if it is
more the same like we were talking about
earlier I'm completely fine with that
with Far Cry 5 like with having planes
and there's almost a little bit of
vanilla Far Cry 2 stuff going on as far
as I'm developing those allies like a
sniper or the dog that seems really cool
I just want to kind of be able to play
the game and have fun but if the story
and the stuff they're presenting is not
handled well enough that it's actually
impeding on the fun then that's gonna
suck because Wolfenstein 2 like I meant
you they leave is way a good way Far Cry
5 I feel like if you're not gonna go
into it then it's just gonna be this
weird brick wall between me in having
fun with it yeah where you just
absolutely find a way to like mentally
divorce those two yeah yeah which is not
a great solution but it seems like at
least the gameplay is fun and like
entertaining enough set like that aspect
is gonna be good I mean one of our guns
for hire was a bear named cheeseburger
read diabetes you can't you can't get
sillier than that
[Music]
you